[Music]
bounty hunting is a complicated process
LD agree
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie they posted a
slightly different version of the Star
Wars Mandalorian trailer and the actors
did a bunch of interviews we found out
what's going on with the remnants of the
Empire Giancarlo Esposito explained
what's going on with his character he's
way bigger than I originally thought he
was going to be during the series no
surprise Gus fring would be a secret
power player within the Star Wars
universe because we also just got the
full Star Wars Episode nine rise of
Skywalker trailer and confirmed
Palpatine for spirit trying to come back
into the real world I'll try to draw the
connection between what's going on
between the rise of the first-order
the Mandalorian series in what's going
on during Episode nine there's a
giveaway for the Disney Plus streaming
service all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
Mandalorian Theory on the video just a
reminder that it's starting November
12th this is also the full schedule for
when Disney Plus is rolling out around
the world the Mandalorian will be
available on day one for the people that
will have access to the app right away
if for some reason it's not launching in
your country for a couple more months or
something like that just find another
way to watch the series until that
happens but they're airing episodes
weekly so it's not quite as bad as if
they were dumping it all at once but
starting with the biggest stuff first we
learned the Mandalorian as you would
probably expect no big surprise is going
to be upgrading his armor through each
of the episodes in most of these trailer
scenes you see him in armor that looks
like it's really worn look at his
shoulder pads they're kind of brownish
they're all kind of mismatched like he's
salvaged pieces of armor from other bits
of armor to form his which isn't
uncommon for Mandalorians there's a
whole culture behind the way they make
their armor no two armors look exactly
the same it's not quite like
stormtroopers where everybody wears the
exact same pieces but at the beginning
of the series if we see in the trailer
Werner Herzog offers him this bounty in
this crazy high price it's a bunch of
best car which is the special metal they
used to make their armor in the last
couple of days they were
a couple new scenes that show him
wearing different armor as if he's
upgraded it already so it must be from
the later episodes you see a new scene
of him with gina carano SCARA dune
character chilling out with another new
character between bounties then there's
a fight scene of him throwing down with
two transed oceans in this one he still
has the old armor you see like the brown
pieces and the shoulder pads either
they're the bounty that he's trying to
collect or they're just other bounty
hunters competing with him for the score
you get a much better shot of his
special rifle that's his main weapon
that he carries with him at all times
but it's modeled after the one that Boba
Fett used during the Star Wars Christmas
special that animated short is the very
first time the Boba Fett ever appeared
there's also another new scene of them
getting ready to throw down inside this
building against a couple other people
he's also wearing that brand new shiny
looking armor that he's already upgraded
so I'm assuming that this is coming from
either the middle of the series or
somewhere later
there's only eight episodes in season
one I don't know if they're gonna beat
that up for season two but they've
already started working on season two so
unless they say otherwise I'm assuming
that's gonna premiere November twenty
twenty next year Pedro Pascal explained
that his Mandalorian character and if it
wasn't clear Pedro Pascal is the
Mandalorian character even though he has
no dialogue in any of the trailer
footage we've seen so far and we haven't
seen him take his helmet off it's not
some bait and switch where he takes the
helmet off and it's someone else it's
always gonna be him through the series
he explained that the difference between
his character in Boba Fett is that he's
actually a true Mandalorian genetically
whereas Boba Fett technically isn't a
Mandalorian the Mandalorian government
actually disowned Jango Fett and because
Boba Fett is a clone of Jango Fett
technically he's not viewed as a true
Mandalorian in the Star Wars canon just
someone who adopts their culture and
claims to be Mandalorian but the real
exciting stuff is actually jean-carlo
Esposito's character like I say Gus
fring secret power player in the
Breaking Bad universe also now a secret
power player in the Star Wars universe
no big surprise there even though you
only see a little of him in the trailers
and he doesn't speak that much he's in
the Thai pilots uniform he's commanding
the Black Death troopers from broke one
his name in the series is Moff Gideon so
that instantly tells you how powerful he
is within the series now this is taking
place after a Return of the Jedi
and after the battle of jakku which was
meant to be the final defeat of the
empire even though they lost a big fleet
in the second Death Star at the Battle
of Endor within the Star Wars Canon the
battle of jakku was viewed as their
final defeat if you're confused about
the timeline the battle of jakku takes
place one year after the Battle of Endor
and the Mandalorian series picks up one
year after the battle of jakku jon
favreau said something recently in an
interview about them exploring the
origins of the first order during the
Mandalorian series because it'll run
four or five years so you have plenty of
time to cover what's going on during
this period but they won't be exploring
it the way you probably think they're
going to explore it because that all
happened in the Unknown Regions they
were at jakku because it was the
location of one of the emperor's secret
storehouses with a super weapon that
they were going to try and use as a
last-ditch attempt to take down the
rebellion there was a minor civil war
within the Imperial ranks and then the
person that one that took the remnants
of that fleet into the Unknown Regions
with a secret map that they had taken
from Palpatine stores so for the most
part the larger Imperial fleet has
already bolted for the Unknown Regions
when the Mandalorian series picks up but
you have people like Giancarlo Esposito
smoth Gideon that are left in the dust
and they used to wield immense power
Imperial moths or governors of entire
sectors of space this is a brief clip of
him talking about his character it's
possible he's an antagonist he was
someone who was very high up in the
Empire years ago very high up officer
he's kind of an imperial remnant of that
time after the Empire fell we have all
of these marshals who are given
different areas to be the top cop in but
I know my character Mothe Gideon has
other ideas and he could be a savior
because in a world that is lawless with
leaders who exhibit kind of a faulty
power because they still have ideas that
they want to
aggrandize themselves the lava tunnel
can I wait to see Giancarlo Esposito
just lord over all the characters
clearly he hates bounty hunters so
that's why he's such an antagonist for
the Mandalorian character but then Carl
Weathers chimes in with lava tunnel then
all the other actors look at him like
he's Tom Holland and he just gave away
something that he wasn't supposed to say
in an interview take out YTD also
explained what's going on with his IG 11
bounty hunter droid he just says the
voice for the character but he said that
he's meant to be naive innocent doesn't
know anything about sarcasm he's super
direct in the responses that he gives he
doesn't know how to lie like he's a
child with a load of guns so they're
gonna be using him for a little bit of
comedic relief like oh my god I can't
believe you're doing all these terrible
things but it comes off as comedy
because he has this childlike innocence
about him while he's doing all this
crazy stuff in the connection to
Palpatine and what's happening with
Snoke during this period is that before
the battle of jakku Snoke could actually
use the force to communicate with
Palpatine so they had a personal history
together just the two of them before the
rise of the first order you can make all
the theories you want about Snoke
knowing that Palpatine's Force Spirit
was floating around because Battle of
Endor and battle of jakku the Emperor
was believed to be dead clearly we know
that that didn't stick because of the
episode 9 trailer confirmed Palpatine
coming back I'm not expecting the
Mandalorian series to completely address
a lot of what's going on during that
they'll mostly cover that during Star
Wars Episode nine because they're
wrapping up the skywalker trilogy is
there to explain what the emperor has
been doing this entire time but i don't
think that it will have anything to do
with influencing what all these people
like Giancarlo Esposito 'he's Moff
gideon character is doing those are all
ants even in force spirit form
Palpatine wouldn't really care about
them he's more interested in influencing
things on a galactic scale if you still
feel like you're confused about what's
going on with Disney Plus don't worry
we'll get more details about that when
we get closer and they'll be releasing
more trailers for the next month too
there'll be a whole bunch of stuff
dropping and because they're releasing
episodes once per week it'll be a lot
easier for me to do videos for each of
the episodes so if you have any
questions just leave them in the
comments below post all your theories it
should be pretty cool there
hyping it up big-time everybody click
here for my breakdown of that Avengers
what-if series trailer and click here
for my breakdown of the Star Wars rise
of Skywalker trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight